[Applaudissements]
merci m adp sur les buteurs en direct
grâce tauriac avait tout à gagner
non gad garder la nuque jusqu'au 16 il
ya une scène comme média et on était
tous au tous autour et tu voudras de
regarder donc adwya à gad elmaleh qui
était un peu en retrait sur le gars qui
postent l'oit us qui se pose est ce que
c'est que le pataquès je voudrais en
profiter pour présenter des gens qui
sont faits pour se rencontrer d'avoir
[Rires]
merci d'être là les cieux c'est le coup
de la loi
j'ai adoré l'attitude de garder chez les
pentes à gaza sont mercredi faut les
voir c'est de la bombe et les bandes
originales et déjà prêt
[Applaudissements]
camille combal ya de la cabine à nate
dans un instant ça s'arrête une séquence
qui qui va être excellent je vous le dis
il y aura deux cabines y aura une cabine
ou iorek